le 14 septembre dernier le président
Larcher recevait le docteur Denis muque
prix Nobel de la Paix 2018 ce médecin
gynécologue obstétricien opère chaque
semaine dans son hôpital de panzy des
victimes de viol et de mutilation
perpétrée dans l'est de la République
démocratique du Congo ces violences sont
connues depuis plus de 20 ans en 2010 un
rapport de l'ONU rapport Mappy dénonçait
ses crimes de guerre or depuis rien ne
bouge vraiment et le tout sur fond
d'enjeux économiques importants dans
cette zone qui est un gros producteur de
cobalt et de coltan donc ma question est
la suivante quelle a été quelle est
l'action de la France pour porter la
voix au niveau international de ces
populations martyrisées qui mérite
certes la reconnaissance mais surtout
condamnation des auteurs justice et
réparation